last men on earth I want to ask you
about this one of the things that I love
about the show is that you will bring
celebrities on celebrity cameos to have
and then they kill them almost
immediately yeah you guys did that with
Will Ferrell yeah my character killed
Will Ferrell spoilers for those of you
streaming Jack Black dead yeah yeah sir
who do you want
is there a cameo that you want you won't
have a star come on and there they are
actually pretty funny deaths when
they've happened they vote they've
always been really funny is there a
celebrity you're looking for you'd love
to have on for a cameo gasps oh I'm
always pitching for Beyonce to come on
the show and it's just falling on dead
ears she's not interested but I don't
think she wants to come on a show and
just get killed right away but I would I
would give her to my show I would give
her a very long death scene right and
that's like one of that's a privilege to
play everybody wants to milk that yeah
so and you haven't heard back from her
yet um I don't know I haven't asked I'm
asking her now Beyonce never what never
misses a cone yeah no you stayed until
after Tracy so why don't you be on the
show if unless it gets canceled then
everyone write your Congressman because
it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you